- All right, hello and
welcome to re:Invent
and to session Industry 3312.
We are proud to share
with you today a story
about how Coinbase scaled their support,
compliance, and developer
productivity workflows
on using Gen AI on AWS.
I'm Joshua Smith, I'm a
senior solutions architect
here at AWS in financial services.
I'll be joined by Varsha Mahadevan,
who is the director of machine learning
and artificial intelligence at Coinbase.
And let's get started.
So today we're gonna start
with a quick introduction.
We'll be followed by an overview of some
of the key AWS services
we'll be talking about today.
These services are
crucial for our customers
to build scalable, secure,
and resilient AI solutions.
After that, I'm gonna
hand it over to Varsha
from Coinbase and she's gonna
go over their vision for AI
and then she'll break
everything down by use cases.
She's going to cover customer support
and then she'll cover
how Coinbase uses Gen AI
additionally for compliance
and to enhance the developer experience.
And then lastly, we'll
close on how Coinbase
sees their path forward.
So taking a step back,
when we talk about Gen AI
for financial services specifically,
it's important to look
at where we came from
and where we're going and
the goals and challenges
that drove us there.
So back in 2023, what
we were seeing is LLMs
for customer and enterprise
just had started to hit the market.
And we were starting to
get questions around trust
and security of data.
These were basic questions.
How can we trust it with our data?
Retrieval Augmented Generation, or RAG,
was critical to businesses
and FSI customers
had a treasure trove of
data that they could use
but they weren't sure
how to make it useful
in a way that was safe for them.
Throughout 2024, after the
release of Amazon Bedrock
and other solutions to
manage secure data access,
guardrails and more,
we saw customers start
to begin to use AI across a few key areas
like customer support.
And the questions then started
to be more around scale,
capacity, and deeper
questions around data access,
streamlining it, granular security,
and specific data storage
or specific tools.
Customers were exploring at this point
how to apply the same
well-architected frameworks
that they were using for
their traditional applications
but apply them to AI to
architect them for future growth.
But now, finally in 2025,
with the rise of more
agentic patterns, more tools,
we're starting to see customers build
fully multi-agent autonomous applications.
And we're seeing customers start to ask
how to completely transform
their core business,
entire departments of their business.
And the question isn't anymore,
how can we build this AI chat or something
where it's a singular tool,
it's how do we revolutionize
the way that our customers
and our employees interact
with that workflow?
And the goal here shifts
into measurable impact
and business KPIs.
So how do we go and build this?
It sounds great, right?
I'm gonna briefly talk
through a few key ways.
This is AWS services for agentic AI.
So whether you're looking to quickly
deploy pre-built agents
to boost productivity,
you're looking to experiment
with open source tools,
you want to build a fleet of
sophisticated custom agents,
AWS provides the models,
tools, infrastructure
and expertise that will help you succeed.
We offer robust AI
infrastructure, custom silicon
and data foundation tools to help ensure
the longevity of those efforts.
This is based on decades of experience
that Amazon has building secure, resilient
and globally scaled infrastructure
and advanced controls we
have for data privacy,
access management,
monitoring, observability
to help customers
confidently deploy these.
And we deploy agents in
every workflow, right?
So we have QDeveloper, we
have Kiro and QBusiness
for prototyping and building agents
and taking advantage of your data.
AWS Transform is to automate modernization
of legacy workloads like
.NET, Frameworks, VMware
and agents in Amazon Connect.
And we also have agents
and tools in Marketplace.
And so if we look at this stack,
all of this is surrounded
by this investment
into interfaces, protocols, security
and network enhancements for AI.
So we'll start in the middle here
where we're gonna focus here today.
Amazon Bedrock is a fully managed service
to help build, deploy and operate
Gen AI applications including agents.
So it provides access to
leading foundation models
like Anthropic, Meta, Mistral and Amazon
through a single API and it
consistently adds new models.
So we have tools to
privately customize models,
some of which we launched this week
and applications with your data.
It applies safety guardrails,
optimize for cost and latency
and rapidly iterate there.
Bedrock also newly includes AgentCore
which is a set of services to deploy
and operate agents securely at scale.
So because Bedrock is serverless,
you don't have to manage
infrastructure for all of this
and again, it's based on
this proven infrastructure.
So Bedrock makes it easy to
build and prototype agents.
However, at the same time,
Gartner predicted in
their most recent report
that over 40% of agentic AI projects
will be canceled by 2027.
The reasons they cited were growing costs,
unclear business value
and insufficient security.
So getting agents to production
is still really, really hard.
So first, the first challenge
you have to overcome
is that you have to deploy.
In order to deploy AI agents,
you need a specialized runtime.
So unlike typical applications
that follow predictable
paths and user journeys,
agents can operate over
very long time horizons
and they process multiple
different types of modalities
and then call different tools and services
to make different pathways.
The second reason is that
as the underlying LLMs
are stateless, the
agents still need memory
to retain context, learn
from their past interactions
and to provide personalized experiences.
And thirdly, you need
fine-grained identity.
So access control to ensure
that agents can access
only the systems and
data sources they should.
Who is this agent and
what can they access?
Fourth, you need to
ensure that your AI agents
can discover and interact
with custom tools
and data sources with the
appropriate identity controls.
You also need to execute
multi-step workflows
autonomously and you need common tools
in those workflows that
are shared or restricted.
And then lastly, you need
specialized monitoring
that is specifically
designed for agentic systems.
So overall, I talked about a
lot of different problems here
but the real message here
is that operating them
in production is very
different than prototyping
with agents in vibe coding.
And so these challenges are the reason
that Amazon built Bedrock Agent Core.
So Agent Core is a modular,
fast iteration approach
to building scalable production agents.
So firstly, if we look at the top,
Agent Core is designed
to simplify operations
and tools for agents.
Agent Core runtime is a
secure serverless runtime
that's purpose-built for
deploying and scaling
dynamic agents and tools,
regardless of framework,
protocol, or model choice.
Developers can reliably
run any type of agent,
including multimodal,
real-time, long-running agents,
which means workloads up to
eight hours running with agents.
It has checkpointing,
recovery capabilities,
and it supports graceful recovery
in the event of an unexpected
interruption or failure.
Agent Core Gateway allows
you to easily integrate
your MCP servers, your
APIs with your agents
and provide an easy way to empower them
with an array of tools.
And lastly, Agent Core
Browser and Code Interpreter
allow your agent to act
autonomously in the browser
or to execute code on your
own terms, your own rules.
If we look at the bottom,
I think of these as
supporting tools, right?
This helps your agents
act more effectively
as they carry out these tasks.
We have Agent Core Identity,
which helps you build
enterprise-ready AI agents
from a security perspective,
an identity perspective.
This has standards-based authentication,
compatibility with existing
identity providers,
and native support for
OAuth-enabled services.
It has a secure token vault
to enable authentication,
to have more frictionless user experiences
for all your agent-powered interactions.
Agent Core Memory, as I mentioned before,
is going to allow your
agent to store and retrieve
short- and long-term memory
for those complex workflows.
How do you continuously use user input,
continuously history, build
on top of a shared memory?
And then lastly, Observability
is gonna help you
centralize your observability
stack for Gen AI,
combining logs, traces, and metrics
to measure performance
and accuracy at scale.
So, now that you have a
foundation of AWS services
for agentic AI, you're set up,
I'm gonna pass it over to Varsha,
who's gonna dive deeper
into Coinbase's use cases.
Thank you.
- All right.
Thank you, Joshua, and thank
you all for being here.
I know it's the lunch hour.
Appreciate you being here.
My name is Varsha.
Joshua already introduced me.
I am the Director for Machine
Learning and AI at Coinbase,
and today, I'm excited to share
how we're leveraging generative AI
to elevate both our customer experience
and our internal productivity.
So, let's start with a bigger picture.
Coinbase. Coinbase is a crypto exchange.
But what is crypto,
and why does it matter?
Right.
So, crypto empowers economic freedom.
It ensures fair participation
in a global economy.
At Coinbase, our mission is
to expand economic freedom
to over a billion people.
We do this by providing a
secure and trusted platform
for both individuals and institutions
to trade and transact crypto assets,
and do so safely and globally.
To truly deliver on this mission,
we have to concentrate
on three key pillars.
So, first is we build trust,
and that means we need to
safeguard our users' assets
with top-tier security, and
put in place strong protections
against things like fraud
and account takeovers.
Second is making crypto accessible.
We do this by designing experiences
that are intuitive and personalized
with the power of AI and machine learning,
and we simplify what can otherwise
be very complicated financial products.
The third is scaling globally.
So, we operate efficiently
and move quickly,
supporting millions of users
across 100-plus countries,
and we manage billions of
dollars in trading volume.
So, these pillars are
really the foundation
of everything that we do.
So, at Coinbase, AI and machine learning
aren't just buzzwords.
They're really fundamental to
how we operate our platform.
Let's take a look at how, right?
And let's just play along with me.
This is about the user's
journey on the platform.
So, let's say the user comes
in, and they want to log in.
So, at the point of login,
ML models are at play,
and they defend against account takeovers.
So, one use.
The second is, let's say
now the user's logged in,
and now they want to
move some fiat currency
into the crypto exchange.
Once again, ML models evaluate
the legitimacy of the user
and the risk of any credit defaults.
The third is, now let's say the user wants
to move some funds from
the centralized exchange
onto the blockchain.
Once again, ML models are at play,
and they play a pivotal
role to assess risks
of any reversals before
the funds are released
onto the blockchain.
So, that was about safety and security.
But that's not all, right?
So, we use ML to personalize every part
of the user experience.
We do this through
personalized search results,
tailored news feeds.
We've got intuitive recommendations,
real-time price alerts,
you name it, right?
Now, all of these ML-powered experiences,
whether it's for security
or for personalization,
all of these use advanced
deep learning models.
And these models are trained
on massive data sets.
The training and the inference for these
run on a platform called Anyscale.
I presume many of you have heard about it.
It is a cloud platform that is based
on an open-source framework called Ray,
and we operate Anyscale
on an AWS EKS cluster.
Now, having talked about some
of these traditional uses
of machine learning for
safety and personalization,
now let's talk about some of the,
what is at the intersection
of blockchain and AI?
Let's talk about some
of the innovative work
that we've done in this space.
So, the first one I'd like
to draw your attention to
is we've built an adaptive
and highly scalable
risk-scoring system for
blockchain addresses.
These are based on graph neural networks.
This is a powerful tool
and has been instrumental
in detecting and blocking
malicious blockchain addresses,
and therefore they protect our customers
from transacting with
these malicious ones.
Another exciting innovation is
ERC-20 Scam Token Detection.
Once again, this brings
together two technologies.
One is smart contract auditing,
and the other is machine learning.
So, this solution helps us review assets
before they are listed on an exchange,
and therefore it provides our
customers more protection.
And the third one here is a predictive
machine learning model.
So, all of us know about
the volatility of crypto.
I mean, how many of you
are investors in crypto?
Show of hands, yeah?
Okay, cool.
So, we all know about how
volatile the crypto market can be,
but in the scheme of this volatility,
we still want to run a very
reliable infrastructure.
And to do this, we have
these predictive models.
They allow us to scale
our back-end databases
before a surge can occur.
So, all together, these
innovations are a great example
of how we are using
machine learning actively
to shape the crypto landscape.
All right, so now let's
shift gears, right?
So, we've talked about all
of these traditional usages,
and including some
innovations and whatnot,
but now let's talk about a new generation
of AI investments that
we've been doing lately.
No surprise, LLMs, right?
So, LLMs, as we know it, have
transformed the landscape
ever since November of 2022.
I think it's like, you know,
it's a historic moment.
All of us talk about pre-
and post-ChatGPT era.
So, there are three key areas
that I'd like to talk to you about
where we are applying generative AI.
So, the first of them is
about customer support.
So, we leverage AI-powered
virtual assistants,
and we also build advanced tools
to support our human agents.
And together, these two capabilities
enable smarter and more
scalable customer interactions.
The second that I would
like to talk to you about
is about compliance.
So, Gen AI is helping us
streamline complex investigations
and navigate the regulatory landscape.
The third is, how can we not talk
about developer productivity?
I mean, all technologists
in the room, I presume.
So, yes, so I will touch upon
how we are improving developer
productivity at Coinbase.
So, let's dive a little
deeper into each one of these,
starting with Gen AI transforming
customer support at Coinbase.
All right, so let's take
a moment to understand
the unique challenges of delivering
exceptional customer support
in the world of crypto.
The first is, crypto
is incredibly volatile.
We just talked about it, right?
User activity can swing up and down
by a good 50% within a month, even.
So, this kind of unpredictability
puts a lot of pressure
on our support systems.
We simply cannot scale
human support quickly enough
to match these rapidly
expanding user base.
The second is trust.
Trust is everything, right?
Our customers need to
feel safe and supported
no matter what's happening in the market.
The third is, we operate globally.
So, this means we have to support users
across different languages and regulations
and expectations requiring solutions
that are flexible and adaptable.
This is where Gen AI
enters the arena, right?
So, Gen AI helps us
overcome these challenges
and deliver great customer support
no matter the market conditions.
All right, so we've crafted a strategy.
So, I'm gonna get into the technicalities
at this point a little bit.
So, we've crafted a strategy
that focuses both on the
breadth and the depth.
So, these are important aspects.
So, in the breadth, what we do
is that we have an
internal Gen AI platform
that integrates multiple LLMs
and also taps into a wide
range of data sources.
And all of these access points
are through standard interfaces.
So, we use OpenAI's API
standards when accessing LLMs
and we also use Model Context
Protocol or MCP standards
when accessing any of our data endpoints.
So, this Gen AI platform
allows every team at Coinbase
to easily leverage and
extend our AI capabilities
for their use cases.
When it comes to the depth,
we are making targeted investments
in a few high-impact areas
within customer support.
The first is we are automating
the customer-facing workflows
with conversational chatbots.
The second is we're providing
our human support agents
with intelligent tools to
improve their effectiveness.
And the third one is we also use Gen AI
to extract valuable insights
from support tickets
to help us continually improve
our products and services.
So, actually, these use cases
that I just talked about,
they form sort of a cycle, a continuum.
So, let's look at how, right?
First, the customer comes in.
The customer requires some kind of help.
They first interface with
the AI-powered chatbot
and get instant assistance if possible.
For the more complex cases,
they get escalated to a human agent
and then the human agents are equipped
with real-time AI-assistive tools.
One more use of AI.
And then next, if post-contact,
AI extracts all sorts of patterns
so that we glean insights
and we're able to improve our products.
Lastly, once the product updates,
we reduce the need for support
and we also create more knowledge
to be able to automate the support.
So, it's this whole cycle with a feedback
that works together.
All right, so now let's deep
into every one of these use cases.
So, we'll start with the
customer support chatbot.
Chat has quickly become
the go-to support channel
for more than half of our customers.
So, trained on Coinbase's
extensive knowledge base,
our AI-powered chatbot is able
to provide instant accurate
assistance around the clock,
adapting to any kind of
market volatility, right?
So, let's look at the layers
in which, the way we built the chatbot.
We built it sort of iteratively.
So, we started very simple.
The first layer that you
see highlighted over here,
it's a very simple FAQ-style
rag responses layer, right?
And so, we started simple
so that we allowed ourselves
to focus on accuracy
and build a strong foundation
for more capabilities
that we wanted to add in the chatbot.
So now, these simple
queries, such as sign-in,
how do, if users have
a problem with sign-in
or two-factor auth or any
other how-to questions,
this layer is able to automate that.
Let's look at the agentic architecture
that sort of underpins this, right?
So, as shown in the picture,
we start with the user input
and any other prior conversation
history that is stored.
We store it in a vector database
and that serves as the
memory layer for us.
The rag retriever is the
fulcrum of this design.
So, it uses bedrock knowledge bases
where we vectorize and store
all of the Coinbase help articles.
And then we also use
coherence re-ranker models
to get high accuracy from
the retrieved rag articles.
We also, the other important
component over here
is the response generation.
This is sort of a mixture of LLMs,
including the cloud models
that are served through bedrock
to generate a very precise response.
This response generation
is an important step
and it actually involves a sub-agent
developed in an actor-critic architecture.
Then come the guardrails, right?
You can see two gatekeepers over here.
You have input guardrails
and you've also got output guardrails.
These guardrails are powered
with bedrock guardrails, actually.
Bedrock helps protect us
against harmful content
and leakage of any sensitive PII.
Additionally, we also have some
custom domain-specific filters
that participate in the
input and output guardrails.
These help us minimize any
chances of prompt injection.
We also have some custom rules
which help keep our responses grounded
and reduce the propensity
for any hallucination.
All right, so we looked
at the first layer.
Now let's look at the next
layer that gets added to it.
As things moved on, all of
what I'm speaking about,
rewind time back to about
18 to 24 months ago.
That's when we started.
As we were building the chatbot
and launching it to production,
we also saw a lot of
movement in the industry
and the capabilities of the LLMs.
We definitely knew that
we could achieve more
out of the chatbot than
just that rag layer
that we had introduced.
That's where this next layer comes in.
As these model capabilities got better,
we enhanced our chatbot to directly follow
what are called business procedures.
From conversationally
collecting information
to actually taking direct
actions on behalf of the user,
this second layer, which
autonomously operates
on business procedures,
it achieves all of that.
Now the best part here is
these business procedures
form what we call a
single source of truth.
This is very powerful.
Just think about it.
You've got these business procedures
that both humans and AI agents use alike.
It becomes a single source of truth.
This is indeed exceptionally powerful
and it gives us a lot of adaptability
to how we train both our
humans and AI systems.
Queries about the user's account
or specific queries about a transaction
that may have been pending,
all of these get automated
through the second layer now.
Now, looking at the same
agentic architecture
that I was showing you earlier,
now this is a little expanded.
It has added these business
procedure capabilities.
We introduced what we call
the business procedure classifier.
So this is an important component
that allows a query to be
routed to the correct sub-agent.
So as you can see, there is a sub-agent
that is emulating every business
procedure in our system.
And this is a router, the
business procedure classifier.
Next, you can also see that the RAG agent
that we saw earlier,
it's actually one of the
specialized sub-agents.
It's just executing a
specialized procedure
which involves looking up
the RAG knowledge base.
All right, so now let's
talk about the third
and the last layer that we added.
This is the capability
to actually do proactive issue resolution.
So by tapping into things
like the user's signals
and active incidents that may
be happening in the platform,
our AI agents are now able
to anticipate common problems
that users might be facing
even before they need
to ask us explicitly.
Hence the term proactive resolution.
So we've powered our
chatbot with this capability
and you can see that layer also augmented
in this agentic design over here.
The proactive issue resolution
layer is another React agent.
And if the bot is not able to
find a proactive resolution
for the user, then it does fall back
to the business procedure classifier layer
that I mentioned earlier.
And as you'd expect, the
proactive agent is also powered
for all of its data access
through standardized MCP servers.
All right, so you've
seen the iterative design
that I talked about.
Now there are a few factors
that were very central.
We held it very important as we chose,
made all of our design decisions.
The model selection is a key aspect of it.
So model selection
wasn't just about finding
the most accurate model that works.
We needed a solution that
struck the right balance
between accuracy, latency,
scalability, and all of that.
And it also wasn't a one-time decision.
We realized that as the model
capabilities were growing,
we needed to re-evaluate
these choices time and again.
So that was a pretty central aspect
to how we decided to operate on things.
The next is the tool standardization part.
I did talk about this.
So we specifically chose to standardize
all of our tools access through MCPs,
or Model Context Protocol.
And it gave us a really strong foundation,
not just for customer support,
but for many other domains
that we were operating in,
in fact.
We also focused on business adaptability.
Like I was mentioning about
the single source of truth,
the single source of truth
of business procedures
that was able to power both humans and AI.
So that gave us the business
adaptability that we wanted.
And above all, we also made sure
that the bot's responses were grounded.
So the factual correctness
of what the bot was saying
was an important factor.
So all of these were important principles
that we always kept in mind,
as we were building the solution out.
Now, we've seen all of these
careful considerations,
but despite all of this, it is paramount
that we are able to observe and monitor
how our chatbot is
performing in production.
So to make sure we are consistently
delivering high quality responses,
we made sure that we were using
LLM as a judge evaluations.
So every chatbot response is assessed
for things like relevancy, accuracy,
potential buyers,
hallucinations, and more.
We actively track all
of these quality metrics
and monitor trends, and that allows us
to quickly spot any anomalies
and step in as needed.
All right.
Now, having talked a
lot about the chatbot,
let's look at one other use case
that I had mentioned earlier.
This is called Agent Assist.
So what you're looking at over here
is a picture of our
AI-powered Agent Assist tool,
which is designed to help our
human customer support agents.
So as you can see, the middle pane
is that of the human
chatting with the customer.
And on the right side is where you see
this Agent Assist tool,
and it provides suggestions
to the human agent to
respond to the customer.
So as we've established,
it's the complex issues
that actually come to the human agent.
So the human agent is actually dealing
with a stressful, highly
complex situation,
and in that environment,
the Agent Assist tool
provides real-time assistance to diagnose
the customer's issue and also mitigate it.
It draws, of course, the Agent Assist tool
also draws from account
signals, ongoing incident data,
past customer support tickets, and so on.
So Agent Assist provides
personalized guidance,
and it generates very precise responses
in many different languages.
That's another important aspect,
because as we talked,
Coinbase serves customers
across 100-plus geographies globally.
So this is an important aspect
that Agent Assist provides.
So obviously, the end
result of all of this
is faster resolutions, happier customers,
and great efficiency across the
board for our support teams.
Let's draw some attention
to the actual numbers here.
So what did the impact look like?
It's pretty impressive, actually.
So today, close to 65%
of our customer contacts
are handled automatically
by our AI systems.
That's a big number.
This automation, consequently,
saves us nearly five million
employee hours every year.
It's an annualized number,
which is significant cost
savings to the business,
and productivity boost, as well.
Most importantly, this 65% automated cases
are now resolved in a single interaction.
Now, this is a very important aspect.
When cases are handled by automation,
they get resolved in less than 10 minutes.
But when cases go to a human
agent, they can be long-drawn.
It can take up to 40 minutes.
So these systems, as much as
they are a productivity boost,
they actually enhance the
user experience substantially.
So that's an important takeaway.
Right, so these results are showing us
how powerful AI can be when
it's operating at scale,
and the difference that it is making,
both to the business and to the customers.
All right, so we've talked a
lot about customer support.
Now let's move on to
another sphere, compliance.
Super important for a
fintech entity like Coinbase.
So let's look how it works.
So when it comes to compliance,
you've probably heard
about terms such as AML,
anti-money laundering,
CFT, stands for counter,
financing of terrorism, ABC,
stands for anti-bribery and corruption.
Now, as a regulations-abiding
financial entity,
Coinbase as a company is committed
to upholding the highest
standards of these practices.
And you do not want
anybody using the platform
for any such malpractices.
So in order to implement,
in order to uphold these,
we implement several
processes such as KYC,
stands for Know Your Customer,
KYB stands for Know Your Business,
TMS stands for Transaction
Monitoring Systems.
So all of these processes,
while they are super important,
they are a very heavy lift for the company
and highly human-intensive.
And to top that, of course,
we have the market volatility
that we've been talking about, right,
which means that the human workforce,
scaling them is not easy.
The second is the regulatory bodies
expect a very thorough investigation
of all of these compliance cases.
And they need absolute,
detailed, full explainability
of all the cases that
go through our system.
So that is a very important
aspect to keep in mind.
And then the third one
is because we operate
in so many different countries,
we have to adapt our compliance processes
to meet those diverse
regulatory requirements
across the board.
So one size definitely does
not fit all in this case.
Right, so once again,
what was our strategy?
We look at the breadth and then
we look at the depth, right?
I talked about this earlier.
So on the breadth, we leverage
the same internal Gen-AI platform
that I mentioned earlier.
So the Gen-AI platform gives
you fluid access to LLMs
and the data through MCP interfaces.
Then the second, but there is something
that is a little
different about compliance
and compared to customer support,
which is compliance solution also entails
a traditional machine
learning model, okay?
This model detects
high-risk compliance cases.
So for these, we rely on, once again,
I had talked about any scale
which is based on the Ray framework.
So we use our any scale based ML platform
to build these traditional
machine learning models
that detect the high-risk
compliance cases for us.
On the depth aspect with compliance,
we built several different
solutions, right?
So we've made some
intentional investments.
For example, we've built these
advanced deep learning models
that are able to detect high-risk cases
in multiple different
compliance processes,
including KYC, KYB, and TMS.
I talked about these earlier.
Beyond the detection, we also use AI
to automate and accelerate
complex investigations.
These investigations involve gathering
and synthesizing data from a
variety of different sources
and we apply these rigorous
approaches of investigations
across all of these compliance workflows
like KYC, KYB, TMS, and so on.
All right, so what you see over here
is a screenshot of another tool
called the compliance assist tool.
So earlier, I showed you
the customer support agent assist tool.
This is sort of analogous,
but this is for the compliance agents.
This is an assistive tool.
So you can see that, once
again, this is AI-powered
and the AI system actually
has automatically gathered
and synthesized information
from a wide range of different sources.
It has pulled data from
our internal systems
as well as open-source intelligence.
The AI then composes a narrative summary
and it also gathers a set of
clear risk-review signals.
Our compliance agents, the human agents,
are now handed a fully-documented,
explainable investigation that equips them
to make well-informed decisions quickly
and with a lot of confidence.
So this is a great example
of where AI is empowering our teams
and it's also elevating the standards
of our compliance operations.
So this is a quick walkthrough
of the block diagram
that sort of illustrates
the agentic architecture
that we follow.
So starting on the
left, our process begins
where the compliance risk models
that I talked about earlier,
these are the deep learning models,
when they trigger alerts
on high-risk cases.
So that's where it all begins
and this initiates what's
called a holistic review.
A holistic review is a
comprehensive investigation
of a high-risk compliance case.
So at the center of this solution
is our compliance auto-resolution
engine, or CAR for short,
which acts as the orchestrator
for the entire holistic review process.
This is where the agentic
AI-driven workflow
comes into play.
It mobilizes both automation
and human expertise.
We'll look at it in just a moment.
So the orchestration engine coordinates
human-in-the-loop process interacting
with two different human personas.
The first is our own
compliance operations agents.
They review the findings of this AI system
and they provide essential
feedback to keep improving it.
And then the second is wherever necessary,
the system also reaches
out to our end customers
for additional information through RFIs
or request for information.
So throughout this process,
the engine also aggregates
and synthesizes data
from a wide variety of sources.
We talked about this,
internal, external, open-source
intelligence, all of it.
And all of this access is through
standardized MCP-fied data connectors.
The end result is a robust
AI-generated report,
which we call the narrative summary.
Now, it is important to
note that the final decision
always rests with our human
compliance operations agent.
After reviewing the AI's reasoning
and all of the compliance evidence
that the AI system has gathered,
it is this individual,
the human individual here,
who determines whether a case warrants
filing what's called a SAR,
or suspicious activity report,
that needs to be filed with
the government authorities.
Because the company is liable to that.
I mean, we are responsible for
reporting it to the government
should a particular
high-risk case be proven so.
This approach brings together
the best of both worlds,
the speed and the depth of AI,
combined with human oversight.
All right.
Okay, all right, so we've
talked about customer support,
we've talked about compliance.
Now, how can we not talk
about developer productivity?
We'd be doing this service.
All right, so this is a hot favorite.
Let's talk about how we're
making a real difference.
Okay, so let's talk about how
AI is radically transforming
our software development
lifecycle, or SDLC, at Coinbase.
So today, as we know it,
AI agents help our engineering
teams at different stages.
It helps consolidate tasks
like coding, ticketing,
documenting, pull request creation,
reviewing those pull requests, and more.
So in short, what we really
have is an AI-powered SDLC
that's accelerating
productivity across the board.
So today, I will specifically
talk about three aspects
of this whole SDLC process.
I'll talk about code
authoring, code reviewing,
and quality assurance.
Okay, so let's talk about code authoring.
The visual that you see
is probably very familiar
to many of you.
This is Cloud Code.
It's a state-of-the-art coding assistant,
and it integrates directly into your IDE,
or it can also be used
from the command line.
Developers love it.
Coinbase developers definitely love it.
This other visual is that of Cursor,
yet another intelligent,
context-aware IDE.
Again, it is designed to make
software development faster,
more collaborative, and more efficient.
So as most of you would concur with me,
developers are a passionate lot,
and they're an opinionated lot, right?
So that is why what we do at Coinbase
is we offer a few of these
best-in-class coding tools
as paved paths, options,
to our developers,
and our engineers have the freedom
to choose whatever works best for them.
So all of these tools, of course,
are powered with anthropic models
that are served through Bedrock.
Now, so we've talked about code authoring.
Now the next step in
the development process
is pull request and code reviewing, right?
So the tool that you see over
here is a homegrown tool.
It is adapted from an open-source tool,
and it's enhanced with
Cloud models from Bedrock.
This agent is implemented as
an AI-powered GitHub Action.
It integrates, it automates
PR reviews, basically.
So it summarizes the pull request
and the underlying code
changes that have happened.
So how many times, as a developer,
you're given this PR review,
it has several tens of files of changes,
and we don't know what is the context.
Not all developers are very
diligent about explaining
what is the change,
why have they made that change, et cetera.
Now, tools like these
actually automatically
summarize that change for you,
and that's very informative
for the person trying to review it, right?
So they summarize it.
Then they also generate
clear natural language review comments
wherever it is applicable,
just like a senior engineer would.
Beyond that, this tool also
enforces coding conventions.
That's an important aspect.
So many a times, human reviewers,
all they're doing is just
explaining to a newbie developer
what are the coding conventions,
how must they write the code better
for better maintainability, and so on.
So it highlights any gaps
in unit testing coverage.
That is another important aspect, right?
And icing on the cake, if
there is any CI failure,
if there are any failures
in the continuous integration system,
then it also provides some useful tips
on how to debug that, right?
So, very powerful tool.
We've seen great yields from it.
I'll talk about the numbers in just a bit.
Now, that doesn't mean that developers
don't have to review the code manually.
It's just, what we do over here
is that all of these
run-of-the-mill aspects
of reviewing the code are taken care of
by this automated system,
AI-powered automated system,
and so that the human developers
only look for the nuanced
aspects of the code,
and so they can deliver higher value.
Okay, next, talking about
quality assurance, right?
So, coding assistants like
Cloud Code and Cursor,
they already allow you to
automate unit test generation,
so we know that,
but we are taking things
a step further, right?
So, the visual that you see here
is another homegrown AI-powered tool
for automated UI testing, right?
This tool brings end-to-end
quality assurance automation
for our web and mobile UI.
It converts a natural
language test description
directly into autonomous browser actions.
This is very powerful,
right, if you'd imagine.
It allows us to test the UI
like a human would, right?
The browser actions are then performed
in a variety of different form factors,
like we use services like BrowserStack
that give us access to
different form factors,
where we can test these browser actions,
and the browser actions are also emulated
through frameworks like
Playwright and whatnot, right?
But this brings us incredible scale
and agility to UI testing.
And even better, right, when
issues are actually found,
this system captures screenshots
and generates structured reports,
making it easy for our development teams
to go address those bugs and problems.
Right, so once again, let's
talk about the impact.
What do the numbers say, right?
So developer productivity is
showing a lot of green shoots,
and we are fairly confident
that this will continue
to keep growing, right?
So today, nearly 40% of all
code written daily at Coinbase
is AI-generated, or
AI-influenced, I should say.
So our goal is to surpass 50% pretty soon.
Of course, we do understand
that every line of code
still needs to be reviewed and understood
by a human developer, and we
know that AI-generated code
isn't suitable for every
part of the business.
Nonetheless, wherever it makes sense,
we do want our teams to harness
the superpower responsibly
and as often as possible.
All right, next, our
investment in the PR reviewer
that I showed earlier,
that's also paying off.
So we estimate saving
about 75,000 hours annually
through these automated PR reviews.
And not just that, it's
also raising the bar,
raising the code quality overall
by enforcing coding
conventions and whatnot.
Next is quality assurance.
Now this one is particularly impressive.
It's achieving accuracy on
par with our human testers.
It's also able to detect
three times as many bugs
as a human would in the
same amount of time.
And it is also dramatically
speeding up the process
of introducing new tests,
sometimes as little as 15 minutes.
Imagine, how does that
compare with the hours
that you need to train a
human tester to test some UI?
Oops.
And when you look at the cost efficiency,
we are seeing about 86% cost reductions
compared to traditional manual testing.
So, all in all, great results.
We're really stoked about it
and we're looking to go places with it.
Now, having talked about
these three dominant domains,
our investments, our impact,
what we are seeing from it, et cetera,
let's talk about what's next at Coinbase.
So, through all of these use
cases that I've shared today,
we can see that we are
unlocking a lot of power,
but truly our mission is to put AI agents,
the ability to build agents,
the ability to get hands-on with it,
in the hands of every employee, right?
And we truly believe we have
many a mile to go towards that.
So, we want to empower
both individuals and teams
to create, experiment, innovate,
and not only bring benefits
in terms of everyday productivity,
but also reimagine how
we offer our products
to our customers, right?
So, as we look into the future,
our focus is now on
scaling these capabilities
for even bigger enterprise-wide impact.
We are working to modernize and upgrade
many of the tools and technologies
that we've developed
over the past two years.
So, note, this is sort of ironical, right?
Like, I mean, all of us
have talked about software
that has been built.
You know, there are some
sessions that I've seen
about upgrades from .NET to
a newer framework, et cetera.
I mean, these are systems
that we're talking about
that have lasted a decade.
But now we're talking about modernizing
what has been built in
the last couple of years.
But that's the nature of
this landscape, right?
Like, AI is moving at breakneck speed.
So, yes, we do need to keep thinking
about how we're going to
modernize these AI systems
and keep up with the
innovation in the industry.
So, that's where platforms
like Bedrock Agent Core
truly come in.
And we're really excited
about using Agent Core
for this next wave of expansion
in our AI investments.
So, for secure, we have
talked about Agent Core
in many different regards.
One is, of course, the
secure agent deployment,
the robust identity and
authentication management
that it offers across both
agents as well as MCP tools,
features like powerful memory,
advanced interoperability.
All of these are very,
very exciting for us
and they really hold
many, many possibilities.
All right, so summing it up, once again,
our goal is to democratize
AI across Coinbase
so that every employee at Coinbase
can leverage this technology
and solve problems
and create value for our customers
and keep us at the
forefront of our industry.
Thank you so much.
Thank you for listening.
(audience applauds)